abone ol
bu
18 dakika başladı Evet ben bugün biraz
Kafamızdaki bazı sorulara cevap vermeye
çalışacağım insan psikolojisi uğraşan
bir olarak zihnimiz nasıl yoldan çıkar
bir yani çok zeki insanlar çok böyle
başarılı İnsanlar bazen çok aptalca
şeyler yapıyorlar öyle büyük hatalar
yapıyorlar ki kararlarını
götürüyorsun Niye böyle Bu karar verdi
diye 80 yaşın üzerindeki bir kişi 16
yaşındaki bir sana aşık olabiliyor her
şeyini feda edebiliyor nasıl oluyor
bunları ele almaya çalışacağım bunu arka
planda ne var bu Tabii sürenize göre ver
Size hap bilgiler vermeye
çalışacağım şimdi en Bu bir duygusal
aptallık kavramı var yok 8 Sen mantıklı
olarak zeki insanlar duygusal o kadar
zeki olamıyorlar burada devekuşu
sendromu diyebilirsin biliyorsunuz
işinin tehlike anında başını kumaş
lokması evi bazı görüşlere göre tehlike
anında başlıklı başlatmak ve yavrular
yumurtalarını koruma davranış diyorlar
ama sonuçta koca gölgesi dışarıda
burada gücün büyüsü yazarak duygusal
kısırlık yapıyor özellikle
diktatörler gücün büyüsünü kullanarak ve
Böyle yük gösterişli ve altyapı eserler
karşılamalar yaparak O büyük üzerinden
insanlar yönetiyorlar hep bunun
örnekleri var hatta Sultan Abdülmecid
Mehmet Emin Paşa bunun WhatsApp'ta
adamların birisi Dolmabahçe Sarayı ve
sarı yaparken ya bu kadar için
borçlanıyor zaten bu içindeyiz bunu
Bu israflı azaltalım dediği zaman sazan
Mehmet Emin Paşa görevden alıyor düşer
Bu yaşadığımız birinci Abdülmecid
döneminde olan bir şey ve diğer bir
duygu salatalık yapan da korkunç korkunç
şiddeti Göksel aptallığı artıyor insan
korktuğu zaman aptal bir şeyler
yapabiliyorlar korkutmayı da burada
özellikle insan korku duygusu nedeniyle
evde okuduğun etkisiyle duygusal
aptallaşma yapıyorlar Hatta Bununla
ilgili güzel süslü Komiserim değil mi
Sen oradan bahsediliyor kişi Örneğin
alınıyor Reyn oldu kişi ona kontrol
ediyor her şeyde ve orada ona aşık
oluyor burada e Stockholm Sendromu Ya
ben birçok bu korkunun etkisiyle böyle
tüm temel değerlerinden ne yapıyor Ben
şeyler yapan insanlar görüyoruz sevginin
yüksekliği de aynı şekilde salatalık
yapıyor sevginin yüksekliğe bir insan Ay
çok sevdiği zaman mesela
evler eşleri düşünün
ve eş aldatma modelini kabusu biliyorsun
herhalde ama en çokta
en son duyan eşler olur niye Evet çok
sevdiği için onu bir türlü yakıştıramaz
Eşinle ilgili şeyler eğer en Sondayım
söyleyemez kimse yok da çocuğu madde
kullanılır Esra kullanıldı onun bahçe
kullandığını görmez duygusal gözlükler
yapıyor insert gözlükler yapıyor aşağı
yüksekliği aşırı istek de zihinsel
körlük yapıyor işe aşırı isteyen kişiler
de evde onun
isteyenin aşırı istek karşıtını besliyor
ve karşı durum ortaya çıkıyor O da hata
yaptırıyor Bu ikinci birçok İnsanlara
kompresörlerde çok inanan insanlar
vardır Her toplumda 105/10 oranında
vardır ama bu komplet Örneğin an
kişilerde için aşı olan doldurmuş gibi
kompresör neden
olmuyorlar ve bu yüzden
anca bir kurban olan kişi örnekleri var
bardak operatörlüğü yapmakta bir diğer
ucunu alışma hastalığı vardır burada
sendromu vardır üçünü çalışma sonunda
insan farkında olmadan senelerce aynı
şeyi çocukluğundan beri aynı şeyi yaptı
için o yaptığı şey nedeniyle Ümit de
sonra onu ve aynı hataya devam eder
Hatta bu da işletme körlüğü dönüyor buna
birçok işletmede bağımsız denetçiler
alır çok işletme körlüğü gidermek için
içine alışma neresidir onu düzeltmek
için bunlar duygusal haftalık yapan bazı
örnekle başka bir örnek bıraktığı
salatayı biliyorsunuz daha var bir dahil
bu Gözüküyor mükemmel Kemal Çalı yüksek
zekası varsa söyle bu duygusal zekası
yerlerde sürünüyor evlerin 10. yılında
içinde şunu söylüyor Senin evli kalmak
istiyorsan ben de şikayet etme yemeğimi
köy düzeni o zaman getir benden dostluk
ve yakınlık bekleme diyor ve bu
Nobel fizik ödülü almış bir kimse aynı
hayatında çocuklarını yetiştirmede Aynı
başarıyı gösteremiyor duygusal körlük
var burada Evet burada değil ikinci
olarak söyleyebileceğim bir zihnimizin
yolda çıkmasıyla ilgili spinozanın
yanılgısını ver Burada vurgulamak
istiyorum şimdi spinoza biliyorsunuz
aydınlanma çağının filozoflarından
spinoza bulunduğu çağrıda bulundu çare
zeka testi akıllı Yakası başlattığı bir
süreç kartın daha sonra Hegel vesaire
Bunlar yorumlamıştır burada Eğer mm o
zaman yalnız ederken spinoza Ya aslında
yaptık bilimsel
veriler yaşadığı çağda ki bilimsel
veriler ona göre doğruydu Ama şu anda
spinoza gelse yanlış boulder
değiştirebilir fikirlerde Çünkü burada
yeni bilgiler ortaya çıktı kuantum
bilgisi ortaya çıktı genetik bilgi
ortaya çıktı doğru bilimin getirdiği
bilgiler ortaya çıktı bu bilgiler
içerisinde spinozanın Aslında
yanıldığını bir niyetli olduğunu ama
yanıldığını rahatlıkla söyleyebiliriz
Şimdi her şey belli diyorduk yirminci
yüzyılda Aslında her şey verdiğin
veya veri her şey tükeniyordu aslında
bir her şey değil Herşey veri evrende
ister tabanı bir Evren var iptal devam
devrem ya evrende önce önce bir bilgi
var ondan sonra maddi var ya ve ama üç
kuruş görüş öyleydi bak ne gelin görüşü
diğer Lig sorgulaması vardı Ee Gel
birlikte olarak geçiyor bu bu madde
fikir madde ve fikir birbirinin
tamamlayıcısı olarak kabul ediliyor ya
madde ve fikir ga diyalektik
materyalizmin de vardım önce madde var
maddi diyalektik olarak bu somut soyut
bilgi ortaya çıkmış bilim felsefesi
karışmış ama kuantum zannediyor ki önce
bilgi var evde maddenin 5 hali katı sıvı
gaz enerji ve bilgi hali maddenin yeni
keşfetti hali bilgi hali bu bilgi hali
içerisinde o halde önce bilgi olduğuna
göre is bozonlar çay Türk Amerikan
dergisi tanımak çeşidi ve şu anda
özellikle
halk insin görüş var bu beni
matematiksel attım bu dünyanın bu kadar
hareketli canlı neşeli olmasını görüyor
ama bu koca evrenin öğreneceksiniz
hareketsiz boş olması beni matematiksel
attım kabul etmiyor oralarda da çoklu
Evren var başka canlılar ya ondan
Kristof Kolomb'un Amerika'ya gidip orayı
işgal ettiği gibi Onlar gelip dünyayı
işgal edecekler tarzım görüşü vardır
konuşmalarında Bunlar da yeni
matematiksel akıllı ya yeni matematik
modelleme ile Bütün bunlar sorgulanıyor
diğer sorgulanmış aktif genetik şifreler
var anlamlılık Ölüm Ölüm algılama işleri
var ama
zamanı algılama ile ilgili ama ve ilginç
şu an Ruhani arayış gelir en son tespit
edildi basket eugenol
akıllı klavye çok yakında ilgili
gideceğim bugün olan kişiler ölümü
ölümden sonrasını hayatın anlamını bunu
sorgular gelişimizde burada ve devlet
Diğer taraftan da Darwin yaşam bir
mücadeledir demişti şu anda bu
mm Ozan takip olarak düşündüğümüzde
orada Alp bağırsaklarımızda
vücudumuzdaki mikroplardan daha çok
büyük mikrobiyota var
Evet bu müthiş bir şekilde vücudumuza
yardım içinde çalışıyor O halde yaşam
mücadele değil yaşa mücadele İstisna ne
ama yardımlaşma esas şu andaki ve
bilgilere göre yani akla uygun her şey
gerçek gerçek olan her şeyi akla
Uygundur
Ege'nin ünlü sözü ve bu böyle bir
durumda Şu anda böyle bir
evrenin kendini göstermeye bir dışkı
tarafından her şeyi bilen her şey
korkulacak tarafındaki buna bizim Ve
kutsal metinleri mizde buna Tevhid dedi
olarak kabul ediyor en akla varoluş
açıklayan en akla yakın toz olarak bunu
söyleyebiliriz onunla ilgili ayrıntılı
bilgiler bilgelik psikoloji kitabında
duygusu rasyonel ilahi spinozanın
canlısı ve evrimin evrimi gibi
kanıtlarıyla şimdiye çalıştım ve 2014'te
de Arizona Üniversitesi ile olan bir
Üniversitesi'nin ya ve bilim kedi var
ortaya çıkan burada bilimsel zihinler
makal yazın ötesine geçiyor yam pus
materyalist bilim manifestosu yayınladı
124 sayfalık bir Manifesto Manifesto
Türkçe çeviriyoruz ve şuan da web
sayfamızda da bunun ilk Manisaspor'un
ilk giriş kısmı var Bu nedenle şu anda
yeni bilim anlayışı bütüncül bilim
anlayışı sadece madde her şeyi
açıklamıyor madde ötesi bir öp bi limon
arayışına ihtiyaç var ve diğer insan
hata yaptıran
Diğer zihnimizin yoldan çıkmasına sebep
olan konulardan bir şey Tanrı Kompleksi
taşıyan insanlar vardır kendini böyle
özel önemli Üstün istiyorlar narsistik
kişilik bozukluğu insanlar gönder örgü
ile beslenir ve ben öyle bir iş adamı
Biliyorum çok
Marmaris'te balık avlama video çok güzel
çok beğendim çok rahat çok rahat diyor
Onun üzerine arkadaşlar ilk ya burada
rahat sen Niye gelip burada çalışıyorsun
gidip de orada şey yapsana diyor
yaşasana Marmaris ediyor ya balıklar
beni akışla mı yok ediyor bunları şeyi
ya kişinin Alkışla besleniyor nasip işi
la bu kişiler Neyin peşinde koşuyorsun
Kurtoğlu'nun olur burada sürekli
geçmişle Ölmek anakronizm var ya kişi
geçmişteki başarısını odaklanıp o
başarıyla yaşayan gelenekçilik var
gelenek Lig güzel bir şey ama
gelenekçilik Ana kurudi bir kronoloji
çalışmış Yakayı şaşırmış bir yaşamdı
güzellik motor iyisidir giderlerden
napolyon'u düşün İskender düşün hepsi
tezerler düşün hepsi Tanrı kurallardır
kendilerine yenildi Tanrı gibi
itiraz edilmesini kürkünü itaat
edilmesini istiyorlar Bu Faruk Kompleksi
olarak geçiyor gücün kanun ve kurallar
da değil tek kişilik toplanması
despotizmin Doktor haline gelmesi
kendisine zorla k O benim sesi değil söz
üstünün üstünde ne çok sesinin üstüne
güvenen annelik babalık örnekleri düşün
İsrail önüne bağırarak hükmetmeye
çalışan liderlik yüceltir sistem kurma
ihmal edilir
kompleksi'nde Ya entelektüel tevazulu
çözümü özellikle Sivas'ı varsa orada
gelişme oluyor ve bu kişilerde ölüm
yokmuş gibi yaşayan yaşamamış gibi
öldürdüm komşusu sözünü Bu kişiler
unutmaması gerekiyor ki hepimiz
içerisinde narsistlik bir
uyuyan parça var kötü parça bu parçayı
ve içimizdeki parçayı bu şekilde
entelektüel tevazuyla ve
yaşamamış gibi ölürüm
düşüncesiyle kontrol edebilir herkes
burada bak görüyorsunuz Ben narsistlik
liderlerden bir ördek asker ressam çok
disiplinde gece gündüz çalışıyor ipler
harekete geçiriyor Celle büyük Alman
yapar turlu mi Evet yok ediyor fiziksel
siyasal sosyal zekası da cahil ancak
Vicdan zekası yerlerde sürünüyor ve beş
buçuk milyon kişi aşağılık gerekçesiyle
öldürüyor üşütme merhametini insafsız ya
başarırım Ya ölürüm yaşam felsefesi bu
ya başarılı bir ölürüm ve 1945'te iş ile
birlikte İntihar et
narsistlik bir lider olarak şu anda
demokrasi buna borçlu zaman onu da
söyleyeyim yani Batı toplumunu gördükten
sonra ancak demokrasi kıymetini anladı
ve ifade özgürlüğünü ve insan haklarını
ve bir kal der gibi Yaşatmaya çalışıyor
diğer bir sendrom da niyet okuma sendrom
olarak geçirip geçebiliriz ben böyle bir
çok yapılan insan hata yapar yakın
ilişki yaşadıkları bozan durumlardan
birisi geçer dediğin zaman geber anlar
Canın çıksın canım ne zaman canın çıksın
Allah yakın ne vardı Bunu gördük burada
ya Karşıdaki kişi niyetini ve sen bunu
söyledin diyerek niyetin okur niyet
okuma insan en çok hata yaptı Her şey bu
çünkü insan da var bu diğer canlılarda
yok beynimizde ayna nöronlar var ayna
nöronlar bile karşı tarafın zihnini
okuyup okumaya başarıyor beni bizim
beynimizdeki Aynur onlarla karşı tarafı
Beğendik aynı zamanda konuşuyorlar
konuşuyorlar bu konuşurken karşı tarafın
ne düşündüğünü de düşünüyor İnsan buna
tuvalet doğrusu ve zihin teorisi geliyor
Bu arada insanı bir hata yapıyor karşı
tarafın zihnini ile ilgili varsa erken
onun düşünmediğini yapmadığını bir şey
var sayıyor yakın ilişkilerde evlilik
sorunlarına en çok rastladığımız
problemlerinden birisidir Yani söz
duyduğu zaman ne ne
söylediğimi odaklanırız kim söylediğim
odaklanıyoruz Eğer niyet okuma
hastalığına yakalanmak istemiyorsanız
biz bu muhakkak ne söylediğini olay
analiz etmemiz lazım istemiş zihinler
kim söylediler olayı kişiselleştir ve
niyet okul öpmeden bu zaten böyle birisi
de bana bunu Demek ki gelin kaynana
meseleleri düşünün Evet gelin kaynana
meselelerde eve gelin geldiği zaman
Herşey bebek bebek büyüttüm çocuğu
elimde alacak diyor mesela devam
kuşkuyla bakıyor yüzü gülmüyor ki eğer
kendini gerçekleştiren Kehanet kuralı Ya
insanlar hiçbir zaman kötü insan yoktur
Hayatının bir önemli kötü günler geçiren
insan vardır Bu nedenle bir insan kötü
diye hemen kategorize etmek çok yanlış
Bugün kötü dediğimiz insan Yani yarın o
kötülüğü değiştirebilir çıkabilir onun
Hayatının bir döneminde Kötü zan
fenomeni de çok dikkat çekmek gerekiyor
insanın hata yaptırıyor Niye
sokuyorsunuz kötü zanda buluyorsunuz
burada tak ve çözüm olarak ne çözüm
öneriyoruz bakın burada çok Üniversitesi
ve bu pratik bilgelik Merkezi açmış
Birkaç yıl önce Yeni açmış ve burada ve
bilimsel bir bilgelik Sırf bu insan
ilişkilerindeki Jack insanların hatalar
yapması vs Nokia neden
üzüyorsun röportajını okudum ben niye
kaybettiniz diyor Biz hiç yenilmeyeceğim
izi düşünüyorduk diyor burada ne oluyor
iflas erteleme
tekli gerekiyordu her kaybedebilir
ihtimaliyle yaşaması gerekiyordu onu
yapmayıp ne yapıyor ve kaybediyor bir
diğer Öyle işte buradaki bilimsel olarak
ve Öykü göz önüne alınıyor bilgelik
ilgili bilimsel olarak gözün dağılması
kanıta dayalı bilgi sonra geçiyor Ve
bunu eğer biz bu 21. yüzyılın becerisi
bunu bir hayatımızda her geçemezsek
uçağı kaybederiz bu bilgileri bu Doğu
bölgelerinin Anadolu İrfan üzerindeyiz
bunu muhakkak hayata geçirmemiz
gerekiyor ve burada o bir kitapta Ben
rasyonel ilaç Bir ozanyalı evim evde
konusunu işlerken ikincisinde de yıl
doğru güzel bulma sanatı gibi çeşitli
Böyle öküz bir hikayelerinden mesela
okuyorum Çok tavsiye ettiği bir gerçek
hikayesi tostun bir yeri vardır Tolstoy
müziği olarak yaşarken yaşayan birisini
gönder Ne yapıyorsun diyor hoşgörü
oturuyor zannediyor benziyor ve bir
yılanla uğraşıyorum Şahin uğraşıyor bir
Kartallı uğraşıyor vesaire hiç kimse yok
yanımda diyor Hayvanlar nerede Kartal
diyor Ellerim diyor Şahin diyor
yılan diyor dilim diyor ve teşekkür
ayaklarım diyor bir ediyoruz tembellik
yapıyor ve bunları ekmekle uğraşıyorum
diyor yani sonuçta hepsi Biz kendimizi
Dünya'yı değiştirmek kendimizden
başlamak çok önemli kendim bu ve
aklımızı kalbimizi gözümüzü dilimizi
duygularımızı düşüncelerimizi
davranışlarımızı yönetebilme nin
bilimidir bilgelik filmi bunu
zihin zihnimizin yoldan çıkması da çözüm
olarak ve bilimsel bilgeliği rahatlıkla
söyleyebiliriz teşekkür ederim